speaking of people that make you laugh
uh Sam Harris
um he's actually has a really great
sense of humor he does with a very cold
and monotone delivery he's another one
that you had um you're friends with you
have good conversations with what uh
what is your fundamental disagreements
and agreements with Sam Sam believes
that religion is intellectually
indefensible he really believes it like
deep in his soul
um and and he gets angry at the idea
that a proposition
should be unchallenged if it offends his
sense of logic yeah so he cannot move on
until this is done in fact uh I I mean
he you know I did a podcast with Eric
Weinstein and then Sam did one and Sam
said when I heard your podcast with
David wolpe I learned stuff about what
he thinks that I never learned in my
conversations with him because I can
never let him make those unfounded
assertions without challenging them and
you just let them go and I think that
there was something too that was like
he finds it hard to have a conversation
about religion
that doesn't arouse his real ire about
the harm that he thinks religion does in
the world so it's more about the
implementation of religion in the world
as it is versus the really fundamental I
think he also thinks it's fundamentally
intellectually shoddy and disreputable
Faith yeah faith
I don't know how to put this I mean
they're both capable of separating their
contempt for religion
from the people that they have sitting
in front of them you mean Christopher
Hitchens and Sam Harris yes both of them